if I were a smart musician I would have
done what the other smart musicians did
which is only license your music and
places where they don't speak English
you know that's at me all the credible
musicians I don't want to name names but
they don't license their music in the UK
or the states they license it in
Portugal or they license it in South
Korea or Japan and that way the
tastemakers you know the music
journalists never hear about it but it's
it's a strange phenomenon because I mean
I have been criticized for licensing my
music to commercials but it's odd for a
few reasons one that most of the
journalists who criticized me write for
publications that are wholly funded by
ad revenue you know so there'll be an
article criticizing me for liking my
music to commercials and on the next
page an ad for Ford or Budweiser or what
have you and the same journalists who or
people who criticize me for licensing my
music actually you know buy the products
that are being advertised and I don't
know I may be the old punk rocker and me
I always thought it was cooler to take
money from a big corporation and to give
money to a big corporation so I have
regrets that I did too much licensing
and I should have as I had been smart
and done what everyone else does his
only licence at South Korea in Japan
when play came out at first it didn't
have any success you know the reviews
weren't very good it didn't sell very
well and then it sort of picked up
momentum and became a successful record
so at first the only the only way I had
to get people make people aware of the
music was by licensing it to movies TV
shows advertisements so we did a lot of
it in hindsight I think I did too much
of it there's another ironic aspect of
it which is that at the time people in
the music business be the musicians or
record executives heaped scorn on me for
doing this and now those same record
executives are all working at licensing
companies or they're working at record
labels where they're desperate to
license anything and a lot of the
musicians who also criticize me are now
bending over backwards and prostrating
prostrating themselves to try and get
their music license
so I think that unfortunately I I don't
mean this in a positive way I was sort
of the avant-garde of Licensing you know
I was like the shock troop of Licensing
so as a result I got killed first you
know so now everyone does it and no
one's really criticized for it but yes
in hindsight I definitely did way too
much of it but the only reason I got
involved in the music business it was
because I love music and I want to make
music and selfishly I'd like people to
hear the music that I make I'm not too
concerned with the commercial
ramifications of producing and producing
music and putting it out into the world
if people want to buy my music fine if
they don't want to that's fine with me
too again my my only interest in the
commercial side of the music business is
to try and get people to hear the music
that I've made you know so I don't I
don't look at the music business and
think how can I make a lot of money from
it I look at it and I think how can I
strategically try and get people to hear
the music that I've made and so when I
look at the the fact that the record
companies are falling apart and revenue
streams are dying drying up and
royalties are you know 1/10 what they
used to be for a lot of people it
doesn't concern me some from sort of
like a fiduciary perspective it only
concerns me from a musician's
perspective where I just hope that in
the future I'm able to make music that
people will be willing to listen